all right we got one more story for you
this one is really just crazy and
it's such a sign of the times and it's
such a perfect example of why social
justice and wokism
as they are being packaged and infecting
our entire
system why they are so deeply dangerous
because we they are going to take out
every institution
they are going to infect everything that
brings us together and we're going to be
turning on each other if we're if you
think we're turning on each other now
until we break the back of wokism until
we actually reject it all together in
unison
it is going to continue to destroy every
bond that brings us together as
americans
uh so yes they are going to be playing
the black
national anthem at nfl games this is
absolutely bananas i've got some quotes
here from
former sports network now racial justice
network espn
lift every voice and sing traditionally
known as the black
national anthem is expected to be
performed live
or played before every week one nfl game
and the league is considering a variety
of other measures during the upcoming
season to recognize
victims of police brutality a source
familiar with the league's discussions
told the undefeated on thursday having
recently displayed
increased awareness about problems of
systemic racism the nfl in collaboration
with the nfl players association is also
considering listing the names of victims
on uniforms through decals on helmets
or patches on jerseys the nfl also may
produce
educational programs about victims among
other plans
early last month commissioner roger
goodell in a video admitted that the
league
had erred in how it handled peaceful nfl
player protests
of police brutality and systemic
oppression goodell condemned racism and
affirmed that black lives matter
pledging his allegiance to the players
in the battle
for equal justice under the law also in
june the league revealed plans to
increase its social justice footprint
by pledging to donate 250 million
dollars over a 10
year period now first off i would like
to say that roger goodell
you've got good in your name you're a
good man and you should step down
because as a white man
surely roger there must be a black man
who could do that job so don't just be
about diversity and inclusion
let's get a black man in that job you've
got plenty of money go
retire go move to wherever it is
that old rich white people move play
golf
do your thing be a true wokester and
social justice warrior uh joking aside
guys
this is so dangerous this is so
absolutely dangerous first off
we have one national anthem let's just
be very clear about that we are a nation
and if we are one thing it is americans
here and it doesn't mean we have to
agree on everything obviously
but we now have a virus in the system
that is here to destroy the whole damn
thing and
just try to imagine so you go to an nfl
game week one right
and they play the black national anthem
now first off is everyone supposed to
stand for the black national anthem or
are only black people supposed to stand
for it
do i have to pledge allegiance to the
black national anthem do i have to put
my hand
over my heart so now are some people
gonna stand and some people are gonna
sit
and then what happens and here's the
really sort of insidious part of this
thing so okay they're going to play the
black national anthem first
now first also just the phrase black
national anthem
you could have a song that is that is
sort of about black history or something
like that whether or not it should be
played at a
at a sporting event as a separate thing
but a black nationalism implies that
they have a separate nation
and that is a big problem we have one
nation under god it's in the documents
right okay
but the bigger problem is okay so they
play the black national anthem now
they're going to play the
uh regular national anthem the thing
that we've been playing for hundreds of
years before sporting events and other
sort of big events here uh in america
well now are the people that just
pledged allegiance to the other national
anthem are they gonna sit down
are they not gonna you know put the hand
over the heart are they not gonna
sing or recite or anything else this is
designed
to rip us apart and then of course the
league
which is gonna put 250 million dollars
over a 10-year period
towards black lives matter and other
social justice causes i mean black lives
matter which just came out in essence in
support of the government of cuba as
it's repressing its people
and is an avowed marxist organization i
know they deleted that part from the
website but i think you guys know what's
up
um it's designed to destroy everything
so
to be quite honest uh if i was an nfl
fan
i don't really care about football it's
not really my thing i actually i mean i
watch the super bowl but like i pretty
much
that's it it's like i'm kind of over it
all together like it's not even worth
watching that at this point so let these
things
destroy themselves and if a bunch of
people who make millions and millions of
dollars
a year to play football want to sit for
the national anthem
want to sing their special anthem
you know want to ignore the flag or turn
their back to it or or all the series of
things that you can do
this will just destroy us even further
there will be fans
looking at other fans in the audience
going he's not singing the black
national anthem
i mean should black people in the crowd
be allowed to yell
at white people for not pledging
allegiance to the black national anthem
should
white people be angry at black people
who sang for the black national anthem
but then sit for the regular national
anthem
it's designed to divide and destroy and
i'm here to build
and uh to to make sure that we don't
destroy this whole damn thing and that's
why i like that you're on this journey
with me